foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
this is James page at the ftth council
meeting in Madrid and I'm with David
elfassi vice president of altitude
David thank you for coming and talking
to us one of the key things being talked
about at the conference is how we stay
on track with the goal of delivering
full fiber to everyone everywhere how do
we stay on track I will talk only our
friends I come from France so in France
we have a specific French model because
the government launched in 2010 a
national plan and the government decided
to Define three different areas the
first the first one is the very dense
harriers it represents 7 million home
past you can have other build and in
reality you have four fiber for each
home the second one is the medium dense
Harrier it represents 16 million home
past
in this part it's only private invest
essentially by uh orange and sfr
but it's also like a monopoly only one
construction no other possible and the
third part is the we call it pin area
it's less than Zaria pin it means a
public initiative initiative Network
uh it represents uh 18 million own past
and our activities specifically in the
less dense area and we have influenced
to develop 5 million on past and due to
this model and uh also uh all the rules
are fixed by the regulator they are sep
and at the end of two uh in 2025
probably most of the parts of France
will be covered by ftth more than 90 to
95 percent
okay that's really interesting to to
hear how that's structured so what are
some of the things that you're
specifically looking at altitude how are
you helping
okay so we are a natural uh Telecom
operator in France with two
um two activities the first one name is
Altitude Afra focus on b2c Market so we
deployed ftts for family on home past we
have only almost five customers Orange
and by the way we have another uh
another company the name is Kovash and
this company is focused on the B2B
market so it's also wholesaler with
optical fiber on the B2B market and both
of that we are in France the third
infrastructure operator in France just
behind origin sff
uh okay great so um we've heard um that
there's lots of different dates for
different countries Ambitions for copper
switch off across Europe I understand in
France it's 2030 which which sounds a
long way off but but really probably
isn't
um from from both sides of of the
businesses what are some of the key
challenges you you think are going to be
needed to to help you get there oh will
again
um orange announced at the end of the
copper for 2003.
uh we do a lot of uh puck
uh in France uh the last one was in the
east of France and we totally stopped
the copper we decommissioned in the
copper and it goes well
um at the end of 2026 oraj will stop the
commercialization of the copper forever
forever
and the new commissioning will go from
2027 to 2030 so the challenge in the
next year is to be ready for the
decommissioning of the couple because
orange won't continue with the copper
because the cost is too expensive with
uh no Revenue because DSL goes down day
by day
okay is there is any particular
differences between the two sides of the
business will they either find it more
difficult to help that transformation
no not really no no naturally and um we
have also another big challenge in
France because we developed the optical
fiber everywhere in the territories and
we work a lot with the local authorities
you know to to develop iot to develop a
lot of uh capture as we were in the
country to collect a maximum data and
with all this data we we hope that we'll
be more intelligent in the future uh due
to the energy to the transport set to
the carbon in general
yes absolutely it's I think
sustainability is also a key issue
that's been been discussed and part of
that uh switch to ftth will hopefully
result in in lots of carbon savings
I didn't really understand your question
uh it's uh just sustainability is is
really important and switching from from
copper to ftth is is helpful for for
environmental reasons it's important for
one thing our investment
so uh the take-up goes well in France
because we know the the date of the end
of the copper without these dates you
can see in Italy for example or other
the checkup is lower in France uh the
equip is more than 50 percent of
penetration in France at at time and it
goes well we have a more than 18 uh
eight to ten percent each year more so
it's really important to to define a new
infrastructure into in the future so for
each customer if you can only choose
optical fiber that's that's the best way
and
it's real that optical fiber is the best
the best technical uh
um
the best technical way to to have the
best Bend twists and the more uses on
the internet
fantastic so uh
good luck with all the the the the role
of uh of altitude and being able to to
bring that change about and thank you
for coming and talking to us for a few
moments thank you very much and have a
good uh Consulting bye
foreign foreign
[Applause]
[Music]